sarah michelle gellar ruled the 90s as
buffy summers teen vampire slayer but
the decades since have been more quiet
ones for her here's why you rarely hear
about sarah michelle gellar
buffy the vampire slayer starring geller
in the title role ran for seven seasons
from 1997 to 2003.
it laid the foundation for the spin-off
show angel plus a pile of comic books
video games action figures and plenty of
other buffy related media and
memorabilia
needless to say it's an extremely
popular and influential show while it's
not impossible for an actor to strike
gold twice and play the main character
on multiple monster hit series it's
certainly improbable
geller did get more high profile post
buffy jobs than most of her cast mates
with some notable exceptions
david boreanaz and allison hannigan both
remained major television stars on bones
which
ran from 2005 to 2017 and how i met your
mother
airing from 2005 to 2014 respectively
both shows also lasted longer than buffy
but it would be a stretch to suggest
either left a cultural footprint is
enduring
hopefully the studios involved
compensated geller proportionally and
fairly for her work on buffy
as well as for her contributions to
films like 1997's i know what you did
last summer and 2002 scooby-doo if that
assumption is accurate she became a
millionaire several times over well
before she turned 30.
keller's husband and fellow 90s
heartthrob freddie prince jr also
achieved an impressive degree of film
and television stardom in his 20s in
productions like she's all that and
friends
so it feels reasonable to guess that he
also became the average person's idea of
very wealthy relatively
early in his life the couple has bills
to pay just like anyone else
but they're probably not going to be
desperate for a cash influx anytime soon
that means they don't have to take on
every role or job they're offered which
means they simply aren't on television
as much as they need to be if they were
broke
pop culture went to a strange place in
the late 90s in music the decade started
with nirvana
and somehow ended with the all-singing
all-dancing backstreet boys releasing
the top-selling album of 1999
meanwhile film enjoyed a much more
consistent 10 years but if there was a
strange trend in cinema and television
during the 90s it was media that fell
within the vaguely defined teen genre
while buffy transcends the 90s teen
explosion the same can't be said i know
what you did last summer or cruel
intentions
two significant works of the era and
genre both prominently featuring geller
she wasn't exactly typecast but her
persona became very closely tied to a
distinct point in time and a distinct
entertainment demographic
trends go out of style and become retro
cool again in cycles
but casting geller in a 2020 film or tv
show might be kind of like commissioning
dave roll to make a soundcloud rap album
you know he can do it and he might even
do an exceptional job but it just feels
strange keller looked like she was on
her way back to the top of the
television heap as recently as 2013.
on paper the small screen return of
robin williams looked like a no fail
situation
thus launched cbs's the crazy ones on
which geller played the daughter of
william's eccentric advertising
executive
i think that's the thing that people
don't realize is you think he's this
crazy funny
mrs doubtfire or aladdin genie and he's
just the kindest
like most gentle man alas the show only
completed its first 22 episode season
before the network pulled the plug
cancellation after only one season isn't
a meaningful indicator of a television
show's quality
and on the flip side bad shows sometimes
stay on tv for years
the crazy ones was also doomed by
outside circumstance
williams passed away in 2014 a few
months after the final episode of the
crazy ones aired
so even if the first season had been a
bigger success a second season might
have been impossible without a
significant recasting or possibly a
reconfiguration of the entire show
nevertheless the crazy ones didn't
become a lasting hit
geller has a number of projects
percolating at various stages of
development one particular production is
of unique interest to a base of hardcore
fans
here's a hint it's a project based on a
cartoon in which the character geller
portrays fights a skeleton bad guy
voiced by the one and only mark hamill
announced in 2019 netflix's animated
masters of the universe revelation
features geller lending her voice
alongside a star-studded cast
this isn't the only modern masters of
the universe project but it's a whole
lot less murky than the much delayed
movie this isn't geller's first time
working as a voice actor
she also appeared as april in 2007's
tmnt
and has popped up frequently on star
wars rebels and robot chicken
oddly enough she did not provide the
voice of buffy summers in the unaired
pilot of 2004's buffy the vampire slayer
the animated series
if you're the sort of person who can't
be bothered with the media unless it's
related to superheroes space aliens or
some variety of supernatural forces then
it's understandable if you think geller
fell off the face of the planet after
buffy ended in 2003
if you don't tune in to daytime talk
shows or read celebrity gossip magazines
you might have thought she's been
missing all these years
geller is still famous enough for daily
mail photographers to follow her around
while she does normal stuff like go
grocery shopping and pick up the mail
meanwhile the folks at people magazine
think geller and prince adopting puppies
is a newsworthy event
which granted it is but mostly because
every puppy is newsworthy as recently as
october of 2020 geller went on the kelly
clarkson show and announced that her
children are finally old enough to watch
buffy and they binged the heck out of it
to help make the best of the cobit 19
lockdown
she explained i didn't know if they'd be
into it but they are so into it
except i'm the world's biggest
disappointment for them because they'll
always ask questions and i'll be like
i don't remember i'll have to text
someone and ask i think they know it
better than i do at this point
to be fair who really remembers what
happened at their jobs 20 years ago
but my son actually thinks that i'm cool
now
cookies brownies cakes donuts a lot of
the time they're loaded with excess
sugar salt and chemicals we can't
pronounce
the problem is they're also delicious a
few years back geller ran up against
this age-old conundrum
and decided to do something about it in
a 2019 interview she told aol
our kids were really interested in
baking and my knowledge of baking was
all eating and i don't have the time to
get 30 million ingredients
so i went to the store and we were
shocked that in 2015 the only things
were the traditional legacy boxed brands
where the number one ingredient was salt
the lack of baking mix that wasn't
aggressively terrible for human health
prompted geller to co-found what she and
her business associates call the junk
free baking company foodstirs
and if the photos on the boxes are any
indication food stores make some
delicious treats
we just started really baking together
and having these like really fun moments
and there's nothing a kid loves more
than
dough and rolling it and making a mess
in the kitchen foodstirs is also unique
as a professional endeavor geller's
undergone that has nothing to do with
buffy or movies or anything which we as
the content consuming public would
normally associate with her
as it turns out people do have lives
outside of their television personas
geller is a deeply committed mom like so
many mothers around the world but the
key difference here is that typical moms
only end up in the news if they do
something horrible or amazing
keller parents just as hard as anyone
while also being the kind of famous
person who is photographed when she runs
out to the store for milk
raising little ones takes up a whole lot
of time and attention since keller and
prince officially became parents in 2009
child rearing has likely eaten into time
both of them could have otherwise
devoted to acting in r-rated films
screaming cuss words and loudly joking
about adult topics around the house
granted most of those things don't seem
to be of interest to the pair but it's
definitely clear that their kids take up
a major amount of space in their lives
in recent years geller has cultivated a
mutually beneficial relationship
between her media persona and her mom
hood most notably her business venture
with foodstirs was partially inspired by
a family treat-baking activity
she's also indicated taking a hands-on
approach to her son's coveted mandated
zoom learning situation and at least two
unrelated interviews
all evidence indicates that geller
spends loads of time with her offspring
and that's just the way she likes it
geller does quite a bit of partnering
with specific brands like many
celebrities
thus it would be inaccurate to describe
her work in optical health as charity
however even if she's advertising
products she goes about it in a way that
encourages people to make sure their
eyes are in tip-top shape
and hey it's much better to be a
spokesperson for vision than cigarettes
or cheap vodka
according to the daily mail geller was
on an australian trip to promote an
optical retail chain when she told a
crowd of fans
i was working on buffy and getting
horrible headaches and squinting the
doctor on set told me to get my eyes
checked
i had no health insurance so i had never
had my eyes checked
he told me i was blind as a bat more
recently geller's recentered her optical
related endeavors on childhood myopia
apparently fixating on screens all day
is pretty unhealthy for developing
eyeballs
who would have guessed a quick image
search will call up plenty of visual
evidence of geller appearing at
fundraising functions for various causes
but she's definitely invested a uniquely
large amount of time into ucla mattel
children's hospital
geller hosted an outdoor benefit for the
facility back in 2015
and according to the hollywood reporter
she had been routinely volunteering at
the hospital around that time
she told the publication it's hard
enough to get children to go to the
doctor to get a shot
think about what sick children go
through day in and day out what mattel
provides is truly amazing from the
smallest details
like little kids don't use wheelchairs
they use red wagons the window washers
dress up as superheroes
what they do requires a lot of funding
while decided fantasy characters might
be helpful for sick children
it might not be the best strategy for
adults seeing a character from a
nightmare on elm street outside your
window while recovering from surgery
doesn't exactly seem conducive to
healing
in an age when captain marvel and wonder
woman remain contentious topics in
certain circles it should come as no
surprise that female action heroes were
something of a rarity two decades ago
back in the late 90s buffy summers
joined the ranks of sarah connor ellen
ripley and
well exactly a ton of other butt kicking
female characters on screen
at the time buffy was properly
recognized as a milestone of feminism
and lgbtq representation in sci-fi and
fantasy media but in retrospect it's
notable that joss whedon went on to
direct two of the top 10 highest
grossing films of all time
while every other famous person
associated with buffy remained primarily
on television
it's also worth noting that dashing
ladies man david boreanaz went on to
star on multiple shows after buffy
whereas neither geller's ringer nor the
crazy ones got picked up for second
seasons
as talented lucky hard-working and
well-represented as boreanaz and whedon
probably are
they also benefit from the kind of
society-wide sexism that banished winona
ryder to prestige television while
keeping johnny depp
top-billed in major blockbusters long
after the end of the 90s
geller is still very much around but you
have to wonder what she might have done
in the past couple of decades in a more
fair world
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stopper coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you